>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Rob Casper: Hello
everyone and welcome
to the National Book Festival.
I am Rob Casper, the head of
the Poetry and Literature Center
at the Library of Congress.
And I want to welcome you to
the Poetry and Prose Pavilion
and our 1 PM program on poetry
with Marie Howe and Adrian Matejka.
We want to thank the cochairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein
and the many National
Book Festival sponsors
who made this event
possible in 2017.
And those who have
supported it year after year.
I want to make a special shout
out to those folks in the back,
the National Endowment for
The Arts for all their support
to make this pavilion possible.
[ Applause ]
You too can support the festival
with a gift of a donation
by checking the information on the
festival program and on the app.
We welcome your help in making
the festival possible next year
and every year.
The festival would not be
possible without the support
of sponsors and book lovers.
Two other housekeeping
items I want to bring up.
First -- please turn off your cell
phones and any electronic devices
that might interfere with
the recording of this event.
Second -- we will try to fit in
a Q and A after our conversation.
And if you choose to
participate, you give us permission
to use the recording and
put it in our archives,
which is a great and
wonderful thing.
When I got together with
the great folks at the NEA
to discuss this year's
Poetry and Prose Pavilion,
we thought we would try a new model.
Instead of simply featuring
a single poet or writer,
this year we are trying
a few fun pairings.
And our first pairing
features two poets, Marie Howe
and Adrian Matejka, who have
never met, but whose work
and current books have
much to say to one another.
Let me do a quick introduction
and then we will start off
with a reading and a
moderate conversation.
Marie Howe is the author
of four collections including the
National Book Series Selection --
The Good Thief and
Magdalene, published in March
by W.W. Norton and Company.
The poet laureate of New
York State from 2012 to 2014,
Howe's honors included fellowships
from the Academy of American Poets
and the Guggenheim Foundation.
In 1992 she received a National
Endowment for the Arts Fellowship.
Howe teaches at Sarah Lawrence
College in Bronxville, New York.
Adrian Matejka is the author of four
poetry collections, most recent Map
to the Stars, also published in
March of this year by Penguin.
His second mixology was a National
Book Series Selection and his third,
The Big Smoke, received the
Anisfield-Wolf Book Award.
Matejka is the recipient of
fellowships from [inaudible],
the Guggenheim Foundation
and the Lannan Foundation.
He teaches creative writing at
Indian University in Bloomington.
So please join me in welcoming first
Marie Howe and then Adrian Matejka.
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Howe: Hi everybody,
I am so happy to be here.
I just. I am a little.
I got lost [laughter].
Who else got lost today?
I am so honored to
be here with Adrian.
I am his biggest fan.
I have just read his book,
Map to the Stars, this week.
And I just was shouting
out loud in a room
by myself when I was reading that.
So alive. I am really happy to be
with Rob, master of all ceremonies.
This book Magdalene poems
were written one by one
and I did not realize that I would
eventually call the collection
the Magdalene.
It refers to Mary Magdalene,
the archetypical character
who we remember was very,
was one of Jesus' followers.
I grew up in that tradition
and those stories are
really important to me.
But even as a young girl,
I knew that the story
about her was not right.
That she, when I was growing
up in the 50's and 60's,
was depicted by the early
church fathers and most
of the painters as a penitent woman.
And she struck me as being emblem
of the wound many women fell,
maybe all women feel,
which is we are split.
We have been split by the
patriarchal culture into a body
or a soul or a sacred or profane
or the virgin or the whore.
Magdalene was the whore.
Mary was the virgin.
Magdalene was repentant.
Mary had nothing to be sorry about.
That did not seem right to me.
So part of the very unconscious
intention of the book was to try
to approach this wound from the
voice of a contemporary woman
and to try in her own way to kind of
begin to speak to it and to heal it.
Before the beginning,
was I ever virgin?
Did someone touch me
before I could speak?
Who had me before I knew I was an I?
So that I wanted that touch again
and again without knowing who
or why or from whence it came.
On Men, Their Bodies.
One penis was very large and thick
so when he put it inside
me, I really did say wow.
One penis was uncircumcised and I
loved to grip the shaft and pull
down so the head popped
out like a little man.
One penis was curved so I had
to move in a different way.
One penis was so friendly,
I was never afraid of it.
One penis was so slender
I was startled.
One penis was blunt and
short like a little pig.
One penis could not harden until
he stuffed it soft inside me.
One penis came as soon
as I started to move.
I am so sorry, he said.
I have a problem.
But I did not care.
I loved that boy.
One penis pressed against me
hard almost every morning,
but I got out of bed as if I had
not heard a word it had said.
One penis was so dear to me I
kissed it and kissed it even
after I knew it had
been with someone else.
One penis I never saw, but
my hand came to know it
from the outside of his jeans.
One penis loved the inside of my
mouth so much it sang, it sputtered.
One had a name.
One was a mouse.
One he explained to me
had very, very tiny crabs
so we could not have
sex for a while.
One was orthodox and
would not touch blood.
One had a mole, a hard little
dot just under the skin.
One penis was extremely patient
without making a big deal about it.
One penis had a great
sense of humor.
One penis had herpes, but I
did not know that word yet.
One was a battering ram.
One was a drunk staggering,
a lout, a bully.
One slept inside me,
comfortably at home.
The Affliction.
When I walked across a
room I saw myself walking
as if I were someone else,
when I picked up a fork,
when I pulled off a dress,
as if I were in a movie.
It's what I thought you
saw when you looked at me.
So when I looked at
you, I did not see you,
I saw the me I thought you
saw, as if I were someone else.
I called that outside watching.
Well I did not call it anything
when it happened all the time.
But one morning after
I stopped the pills --
standing in the kitchen for one
second I was inside looking out.
Then I popped back outside.
And saw myself looking.
Would it happen again?
It did, a few days later.
My friend Wendy was
pulling on her winter coat,
standing by the kitchen door and
suddenly I was inside and I saw her.
I looked out from my own eyes
and I saw her eyes --
blue gray, transparent.
And inside them -- Wendy herself.
Then I was outside again.
And Wendy was saying,
bye-bye, see you soon,
as if nothing had happened.
She had not noticed.
She had not known that I had
been there for maybe 40 seconds.
And that then I was gone.
She had not noticed that I had
not been there for months, years,
the entire time she had known me.
I need not have been embarrassed to
have been there for those seconds.
She had not noticed the difference.
This happened on and off for weeks.
And then I was looking
at my old friend, John.
Suddenly I was in and
I saw him and he --
and this was almost
unbearable -- he saw me see him.
And I saw him see me.
He said something like,
you are going to be ok now
or it has been difficult hasn't it.
But what he said mattered
only a little.
We met in our mutual gaze,
in between a third place
I had not yet been.
One of the pieces of
information we do have
about the original Magdalene was
that she was possessed
by seven devils.
Oh that is what everybody
is looking at.
[ Laughter ]
Because it is so interesting
because I am looking at you,
but some of you are
looking at her [laughter].
Oh my God.
It is a good thing
I cannot see that.
Woof. You know what.
This is very, this is exactly
what I am talking about.
See there is the split.
There is the body.
There is the soul and we are
trying to bring them together.
So you guys are the soul side.
You are the body side.
Let's hear it.
What an extraordinary
feeling this is.
Glad you are with me in it.
Mary called Magdalene from whom
seven devils had been cast out.
That is from Luke Chapter
Eight Verse Two.
Anybody in the room have any devils?
I am. Thank you very much.
Beautiful Catherine.
Anybody else want to admit
to devils since Catherine
and I have admitted to them.
Oh good, more.
We got more and more and more.
Well I got thinking about
these devils because of course
when they are in the scripture they
seem frightening indeed, don't they?
But of course we are
many of us bedeviled.
So, here is Magdalene talking
about her seven devils.
Maybe you will recognize
the first one.
The first one was that
I was very busy.
[ Laughter ]
The second -- I was
different from you.
Whatever happened to you
could not happen to me.
Not like that.
The third -- I worried.
The fourth -- envy
disguised as compassion.
The fifth was that I refused
to consider the quality
of life of the aphid.
The aphid disgusted me.
But I could not stop thinking about
it and the mosquito too, its face.
And the ant, its bifurcated body.
Okay the first was
that I was so busy.
The second that I might make the
wrong choice because I had decided
to take that plane that day,
that flight before noon so as
to arrive early and I
should not have wanted that.
The third was that if I
walked past a certain place
on the street, the
house might blow up.
The fourth I was made of guts
and blood with a thin layer
of skin lightly thrown
over the whole thing.
The fifth was that the dead seemed
more alive to me than the living.
The sixth if I touch my right
arm, I had to touch my left arm.
And if I touched the
left arm a little harder
than I had first touched the right,
then I had to retouch the left
and then touch the right
again so it would be even.
The seventh I knew I was breathing
the expelled breath of everything
that was alive and I
could not stand it.
I wanted a sieve, a mask.
I hate this word -- a cheesecloth to
breathe through that would trap it.
Whatever was inside everyone else
that entered me when I breathed in.
No that was the first one.
The second was that I was so busy.
I had no time.
How had this happened?
How had our lives gotten like this?
The third was that I could not eat
food if I really saw it distinct
and separate from me in
a bowl or on a plate.
Okay. The first was
that I could never get
to the end of the list [laughter].
The second was that the
laundry was never finally done.
The third was that no one knew me,
although they thought they did.
And that if people thought
of me as little as I thought
of them then what was love?
The fourth was I did
not belong to anyone.
I would not allow myself
to belong to anyone.
The fifth was that I knew none
of us could ever know
what we did not know.
The sixth was that I projected onto
others what I myself was feeling.
The seventh was the
way my mother looked
when she was dying,
the sound she made.
Her mouth wrenched to
the right and cupped open
so as to take in as much air.
The gurgling sound, so
loud we had to speak louder
to hear each other over it.
And that I could not
stop hearing it --
years later grocery
shopping, crossing the street.
No, not the sound.
It was her body's hunger finally
evident what our mother had hidden
all her life.
For months I dreamt of
knucklebones and roots,
the slabs of sidewalk pushed
up like crooked teeth
by what grew underneath.
The underneath.
That was the first devil.
It was always with me.
And that I did not think
you -- if I told you --
would understand any of this.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka: Peace
D.C. It is good to be here.
So Marie Howe.
So you know Rob pointed out that
I had never met her until today,
but I have been reading
her poems for years.
And so this.
To finally get to be here
with her is this great honor.
And it is also one of those
reminders when you see someone
who is able to do all the things you
wish you could do, but you cannot.
So I was listening to these poems
and thinking ah I want to do that.
I wish I could do that.
But I cannot.
So, I am going to read some
poems about Indianapolis.
Has anybody been to Indianapolis?
You know this is a, it is a. Okay
so the four of us know [laughter].
We are keeping it real
for the Midwest.
Now when I brought
this idea to my editor,
I think he was a little
bit concerned
that people would not
know what Indianapolis is.
But it is a great city.
And I am from there.
So I am going to read
the title poem from this.
And this entire book takes
place in Indianapolis
between the years of 1981 and 1988.
So some of us in the room were here
back then and some of us were not.
It is called Map to the Stars.
A Schwinn-ride away
-- Eagledale Plaza.
Busted shopping strip
of old walkways,
crooked parking spaces nicked
like the lines on the sides
of somebody's mom-barbered head.
Anchored by the Piccadilly disco,
where a shootout was
guaranteed every weekend.
Coughing stars shot from
sideways guns shiny enough
to light the way willing for
anyone to look up enough to see.
Not me. I bought the Star
Map Shirt for 15 cents
at the Value Village next to
the Piccadilly in the daytime.
The shirt was polyester
with flyaway collars,
outlined in the forgotten
astronomies of disco.
The shirt's washed-out points
of light, arranged in horse
and hero shapes and I rocked it
in places neither horse
nor hero hung out.
Polyester is made from
polyethylene & catches fire easily
like wings near a thrift store sun.
Polyethylene, used in
shampoo bottles, gun cases
and those grocery sacks skidding
like upended stars
across the parking lot.
There are more kinds of
stars in this universe
than salt granules
on drive-thru fries.
Too many stars, lessening and
swelling with each pedal pump away
from the Value Village
as the beaming billboard
above flashes first one DUI attorney
and then another who speaks Spanish.
So the sky above is
constantly chattering,
like the biggest disco ball ever.
So one of the things that I learned.
I mean I think writing books
is always an act of learning.
Like, I learned about
all my neuroses.
You know. All my devils too.
You know. And one of my neuroses is
Jean-Michel Basquiat's paintings.
I think they are fabulous
and frightening to me.
And as a black man of mixed
decent, they speak to me
in a particular kind of way.
The bifurcation of art.
And so this is a poem
called Trumpets Up in Here.
And it is after a painting by
Jean-Michel Basquiat called Trumpet.
The sprawl and broken crawl on
the back of Basquiat's paints.
The thin cleft of villainous
pigments wrapping each frame
like the syntax of somebody else's
relaxed explanation of lateness.
What had happened was
below blackened crowns,
below words crossed out as a
reminder of what is underneath.
Potholes, ashy elbows and
breath that, in the cold,
comes out in red light
and complaint shapes.
Three lines from Mile's mouth in
the habit of tardy remuneration.
All of that three triggered
agitation.
All that angry-fingered fruition
like Indianapolis's three
skyscrapered sky when the smile goes
down and even the sun and the
colors themselves start talking
like the same suspicious
idiom as a brass instrument.
Thin throat like a fist, flat
declinations of pastors and teachers
at Christmas at the Inner City.
Shoulders back and
heads up while playing
in holiday choir of hungry paints.
Chins covered in red
scribbles in all of the songs.
So I had this.
I do not know if this is a thing
that is useful, but when I.
So I grew up very poor and it was
something I was embarrassed of.
And I could not talk
about while I was poor
because I was busy trying not to be.
You know what I mean?
And I can only talk about it now
because I am comfortable
in a different way.
But I grew up very poor and then
my mother married my step-father,
whose name is Matejka.
That is where I got my last name.
And we moved from the section eight
housing straight out the suburbs.
And it was incredible.
We went from having nothing to
everything in like two days.
It was miraculous, right?
Opening and closing the
refrigerator to make sure
that the food was still there.
That kind of thing.
So I want to read a
poem about that move.
It is called Outta Here Blacks.
And we were out man, never
going back there again.
Outta Here Blacks.
As soon as Mom married
Pops, off to the suburbs.
A realm of glamorously blue swimming
pools, carpools and a spinning rack
of comic books out front
at the Village Pantry.
We were out of Carriage
House like kids as soon
as math sub turns his back.
We were out like juice
boxes after lunch.
We were on the Westside, nowhere
near our old neighborhood,
like a well-organized
poverty protest.
No moving truck because we did
not have anything to move out.
We were so out of there, I
had to dial long distance
to tell Garrett we had gone.
We were outside our chalk lined
piece of town like a bad pitch.
We were outlying that old spelled
like perfectly spelled
gentrifications.
We were as out of bounds as
the how and why of black kids
with two white parents now.
Desegregation out here.
I got me some ice cream out here,
like an Eddie Murphy
impersonation by the watercooler.
We were as uncomfortable as a
black joke in our air conditioned
and well-festooned new home.
Man, alright.
So I am just going to
read two more poems.
I am going to read them
about the suburbs, right?
Because it is one thing
to think about not having.
It is another thing to realize
everybody in the suburbs
in the 80's played
Fleetwood Mac [laughter].
That is real talk, right?
So I mentioned the album
Rumors in this poem.
And I also mention a thing
called a record changer,
which some of us will
know, but others do not.
It was like an L-shaped device
you put on top of a record player
and then you could stack records
on top of it and they would drop
down like a pretend continuos play.
So in this poem, this guy has
his record changer and he had.
Well I will tell you
after I read it.
Record Changer.
To left of the neighbor's barbeque
variations of the same house ringed
by the same foliage
adolescent bushes there,
green tufts of low lying sky.
Dads red faced and bearded
in the back someplace turning
pure meat over hot coals.
The record player is inside.
Wood box speaker propped
in the windows.
To the right across the still seeded
yard are two storey just as square
and as impeccable as the rest.
We want Prince, but Rumors
keeps restarting itself.
Now here you go again you say.
One neighbor asked, now
where did you come from
and we say California
like Fleetwood Mac.
And nobody asked anything else.
And because nobody hunts
for dinner in the suburbs,
we put down our implements
of half step and appetite.
Side step the moon as it
descends into a whole plate full
of charred thighs and wings.
We collectivize the back in
the days ways as tenaciously
as chicken legs undress
themselves at a cul-de-sac party.
Then we raise those stripped
bones up for history.
Out here, there is not any history.
So history is whatever
you want it to be.
So here is what I was
about to tell you.
So this guy, this bearded
man who had this barbeque,
which was the first
barbeque I had ever been to.
Do you realize how much
food is at a barbeque?
If you have never been
to one, it is incredible.
Stacks and stacks.
He had four copies of Fleetwood
Mac's Rumors and he put them A side
to B side [laughter] like this.
And these things keep dropping down
and it just keeps going
over and over again.
And you know I get it now.
It is a good album [laughter].
It is not Prince.
Alright. So I am going to
read a poem about the next day
and then one very small
piece of a poem for Marie.
So this is the next
morning after the barbeque.
Strange Celestial Roads.
There is a father sleeping it off in
every master bedroom of every house
in the cul-de-sac the morning after.
So Saturday morning is a snooze.
The moon is still out,
eyeballing the quiet street
like Sun Ra did his Arkestra.
Somebody had to be a father figure
for all of those musical notes.
No school busses to huff after.
No mothers yelling
their children onward.
The only weekend noise
is us kicking rocks.
So bored we cannot even hear
each other on a celestial swirl
of asphalt that will be
a playground one day.
We stand, right feet extended
in unison like foos men,
rock after rock arcing at sorry
angles toward the open bar
that hopes to dangle four swings.
Some rocks go through, some miss
as we balance on concrete meant
to backstop hop scotch and
echo knock-knock jokes.
Not somebody's father yelling
you got to be kidding me,
after he opens the
property tax bill.
These bars were placed here for
some other future kids to be dragged
from by big ears or
hair matted necks back
to the unavoidable arguments.
The fist-to-face noises
and the sweet bleating
saxophones that come after.
Alright. So this is the last
thing I am going to read.
In the middle of this book is
a very long poem called Sounds
in Sequential Order.
And it is based on the music
or the classifications of music
on the record, the golden record
inside the Voyager's Space Probe.
And I am just going
to read two of them.
Rob thanks for this, man.
This is really great.
Sounds in Sequential Order -- Edit.
Music of the Spheres.
Frequencies get lean out here,
echoing like abandoned ghosts
rattling the forgotten umbrellas
and coatless hangers in
the front hall closet.
Everyone just ghosted as
soon as the summonses came
and the exodus sounded like the
stars Jansky did not mean to record
when he tried to fix
the telephone lines.
This part of the sphere does
not have working phones,
so where do we go next?
To the rooms of vacant
advice and gilded paintings
where the have-it-all live?
To their quadraphonic systems
and wood-cheeked speakers?
A golden record in a pulsar map
and binary arithmetic plays at 16
and two thirds RPM's while the
record changer stacks requests
for traveling music.
One LP settling on
top of another LP.
A platter of orbits for the rest
of the intergalactic Voyagers.
Volcanoes, Earthquakes and Thunder.
The fact is the Earth does not rest.
It spins and breaks like an
LP stepped on too many times.
Polyvinyl chloride
backing up into itself --
rawboned slopes quaking
in elemental underthings
when nobody is around to pray on it.
All of these migratory people --
hymnals in hand, who
only know the chorus.
But we want to hear the song
over and over, again and again.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Well these guys.
Oop is this one on?
Yeah, you can hear me.
Well these guys put
their [inaudible] on,
I am sure you feel the same way I do
that this is how two poets
should meet one another
by shaking hands and
reading on stage.
And then chatting a little bit in
front of whoever is there with them.
You were tremendous.
What a great argument for
the variety of lyric charge
that we have in American poetry.
You both read so differently
and proved the power of voice.
I wanted to talk to begin
about the notion of an I,
autobiographical speaker
and a speaker
who is clearly a historic persona.
And what these books meant to you
in terms of getting at that voice.
Do you want me to help you with?
>> Marie Howe: It is not on.
>> Rob Casper: There you go.
>> Marie Howe: Is it one?
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
There that way.
>> Marie Howe: This way, right?
>> Rob Casper: Yep.
>> Marie Howe: I am sorry.
>> Rob Casper: Do not
worry about it.
>> Marie Howe: I do not
know what this [inaudible].
>> Rob Casper: You know what?
Just hold it up.
>> Marie Howe: Like that?
>> Rob Casper: Yeah that is good.
>> Marie Howe: How is that?
>> Rob Casper: Can you hear them?
>> Marie Howe: Can you hear me?
[Multiple speakers].
There was no historical
persona in my book.
>> Rob Casper: Cultural persona.
>> Marie How: Yeah, but
she is me [laughter].
She is me and every
other woman I know.
You know, so I do not
mean to say only me.
But I really meant her to
be a contemporary woman.
Because women, we still have not
told the whole truth about our life.
And we still are too split.
So yes, yes it is Magdalene.
But Magdalene, as a seeker,
as a someone who is owning her own
subjectivity, who is the subjective
of her life and not the
object of someone else's.
You know.
>> Rob Casper: Did she
give you any freedoms?
That sort of imposing that,
that, the history, the culture.
>> Marie Howe: Well it is always
free to wear a slight mask.
Even if you go to a party and you
just wear the little black mask
like this and everybody knows it
is you, don't you feel better?
[Laughter].
So you can say a lot of things
that you would be scared to say
in another time and place.
So Magdalene is every
woman who ever lived.
She is every woman living now being
gang raped in the Congo right now,
being you know, trying to work in
congress or in this city, you know,
who is becoming a transgendered
person.
I mean she is, she
to me is the female,
the feminine rising principal,
who is you know trying
to integrate aspects
of herself together.
So she was a great person to, that
mask to put on because she has been,
she has been how do I say --
hijacked you know by
the early church Fathers
and held there for so long.
And every woman knows here that you
know we still do not have enough
archetypes that can integrate
all aspects of human life
for a woman in our imaginations.
>> Rob Casper: Well,
Adrian, you had turned
to a historic figure
in your third book.
And then moved in a deeply
or clearly autobiographical
direction with this.
Can you talk about the
experience from three to four?
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Well I was thinking about that idea
of mask and what a great gift it was
to be able to you know
through research
and work adopt a mask
of Jack Johnson.
And be able to sort of tell these
stories and interrogate the kind
of political and social actions
that I cannot really address myself.
Right? I mean he is, his
narrative is one that,
it goes much beyond anything
that I have ever experienced.
And also he was brash
figure and you know amazing.
And we change clothes
five times a day
so everybody can see
how resplendent he was.
But he also kicked
everybody's ass in the ring.
And so he is in this position
where he is both capable
of great celebration
and also great violence.
And I do not feel.
Like I do not have
that in me, right?
I do not have that
kind of [inaudible],
like that kind of machismo.
I do not have that
kind of magnetism.
And so to put on the mask and
have that for a little while
or at least vicariously have
it was a great, great gift.
And when I got finished, I put all
this man's work you know eight years
worth of work and research.
I had to come back
and look at myself.
Like, I can do that for somebody
else, why cannot I do it for me?
And so I went back and tried to
turn myself into a character,
who might be a little
bit more interesting
than I am in my day to day life.
And it started with economics.
I kept thinking about okay I am
position now where I can talk
about what it means to be so hungry
and to be waiting for the school
to open up so that
you can the free lunch
or free breakfast in the morning.
And it is not a conversation
we often hear,
mainly because people
who are poor are busy.
Like I was saying, like they
are busy trying not to be.
They are busy just
trying to make it.
And so it ends up being a kind
of a redemption tale all the time
when we hear about poverty.
>> Marie Howe: But you have got
these figures in this book, Sun Ra.
Am I am saying it correctly?
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Yeah. Sun Ra.
>> Marie Howe: Am I
saying it correctly?
And do you know who that is?
Tell everybody who it is.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah, Sun Ra is
one of the original afro futurists.
He is a great jazz musician.
He said he was from Saturn and I
do not know doubt it [laughter].
But he is a brilliant band
leader and also [inaudible].
Yeah, he used to perform with
this thing called the Arkestra.
And you know, find Strange Celestial
Roads, it is a brilliant song.
But one of the things that
also ties Sun Ra to this book
and also Basquiat and Prince and.
>> Marie Howe: And Richard Pryor.
>> Adrian Matejka:
And Richard Pryor.
>> Marie Howe: God bless him.
>> Adrian Matejka: They
are all black men who grew
up without fathers, like I did.
And so one of the questions I
was trying to interrogate too was
like what it means to figure
out how to be a kind of,
like how to be a man when
there were no men around.
>> Marie Howe: Well they
might have been lucky.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Well that was the thing, right?
I mean like as soon as I
got out to the suburbs,
there was a different
kind of thing happening.
>> Marie Howe: Because
the other men.
I mean, I adore this book, Adrian.
First of all, I mean you also.
You. The black astronauts
and the Voyager one and two.
The wonderful voyagers.
You know it is 40 years.
You know the Voyagers are out
there now going forever and ever.
And it is the music,
the LP's and the.
>> Adrian Matejka: It
is on the heliosphere.
It is past anything
we have ever created.
>> Marie Howe: I know.
[Inaudible].
And they will go forever now
until something hits them.
>> Adrian Matejka:
Yeah that is right.
I do not know if you
all know this, right?
So the Voyager Space Probe is
outside of the heliosphere,
which means it is further out.
It is past the Sun's gravity.
It is past all of that.
Out into the.
So there were recordings of Mozart
and Louis Armstrong
and babies crying.
>> Marie Howe: Laughter.
>> Adrian Matejka: Laughter.
And it is out there.
And somebody.
But they have to figure out
how to play it [laughter].
So, like we do not even
know how to play LP's now.
So how does somebody like, some
you know some space entity going
to find this, right.
>> Marie Howe: You know what the
greatest difference between us
and I was thinking, I mean
no kidding I was yelling
when I was reading this and my
daughter kept saying, what, what?
I am like he is so good.
He is so good!
And what. You are so
good in so many ways.
But you are the master
of metaphor and simile.
I do not use anymore.
I do not use them.
>> Adrian Matejka: So this
is being recorded, right?
[Laughter].
So I can go back and look at
this and make myself feel better.
>> Rob Casper: You
can be, mom, dad look.
Look what Marie Howe says.
>> Marie Howe: No I am serious.
I have got.
This is so dog-eared.
But the whole.
I mean you heard the first poem
you read is such a great example.
Not the first.
The second.
They are all great.
But I mean a metaphor where you
just go like this, this, this, this,
this and the metaphors,
I wanted to say wait read
that again slower so
everybody can hear.
I am going to show you.
Where did it go?
The one Westside, the Westside one.
Moving to the suburb one.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Outta Here Blacks.
>> Marie Howe: That was it.
>> Rob Casper: Outta Here Blacks.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
>> Marie Howe: What page.
Here it is.
>> Adrian Matejka: This is like
the best day of life [laughter].
Can we just stay in here for a
little while because this is making.
>> Marie Howe: No kidding.
Wait. What is it called?
Get Outta Here Blacks, right?
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah, Outta Here.
Yeah.
>> Marie Howe: Okay, so is
Carriage House the neighborhood?
The settlement or whatever?
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah
and it is still there.
And it looks exactly the
same as it did in 1981.
It is terrible.
Same maroon paint on the doors.
>> Marie Howe: So just,
just do this.
Read this real slow.
Everybody listen to this.
>> Adrian Matejka: Which part,
which part do you want me to read?
>> Marie Howe: Just
take it from the top.
Read it real slow [laughter].
>> Adrian Matejka: See now
there is all this pressure.
>> Marie Howe: No, no
just read the words slow.
>> Adrian Matejka: Okay.
If Marie Howe asks you to read
your poem, you read your poem.
That is how this works.
>> Marie Howe: I love that he
is giving me this authority.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah,
yeah, well come on.
You are in the middle.
>> Adrian Matejka: I [inaudible]
stealing from you for years.
So. Okay. So as soon as mom
married pops, off to the suburbs.
Realm of glamorously blue swimming
pools, carpools and a spinning rack
of comic books out front
at the Village Pantry.
We were out of Carriage
House like kids as soon
as math sub turns his back.
We were out like juice
boxes after lunch.
We were on the Westside, nowhere
near our old neighborhood,
like a well-organized
poverty protest.
I am going to stop there because.
>> Marie Howe: Like a
well-organized poverty protest.
Right? It is just gorgeous.
If you want to, just.
I insist. And it goes
on and on and on and on.
But every single one
of them is just.
>> Adrian Matejka: So
this is totally opposite
of how I thought this
conversation was going to go.
I wanted to talk about Magdalene.
So let's talk about her.
>> Rob Casper: Let's talk a
little bit about Magdalene.
We only have so much time.
>> Marie Howe: And
then we got to go.
>> Rob Casper: So maybe.
Adrian you want to
ask about Magdalene?
[Inaudible].
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
No, no. So one of the things that
I was so enamored with was the way
that you were able to work
through myth to recreate
and reclaim these ideas
of what a woman can be
in all of these various ways.
And I am really interested
in how that speaks back
to your earlier work and the
interrogations that you have
and especially the poems.
Like I was.
I posted a poem on
Instagram Questions.
And it is not from this book.
It is from before and everyone
went nuts about the idea
of having a dialogue with a mother.
>> Marie Howe: Oh yeah.
>> Adrian Matejka: I
do not have my phone.
It is in my bag, otherwise
I would read this poem.
>> Marie Howe: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Adrian Matejka: So
that you could hear it.
>> Marie Howe: I learned
that from Alan Shapiro.
>> Adrian Matejka: Really?
>> Marie Howe: You know that
great book, Song and Dance?
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Marie Howe: It is
the greatest book.
One of the greatest books ever.
And also from Brenda Hillman,
you know who has this other
voice talking with her.
Everything any writer does
they learn from somebody else.
>> Adrian Matejka:
That is really true.
>> Marie Howe: Truly.
I mean just like musicians, right?
Because what we do is instead
of listen, we read and we take
in other people's poems and
possibilities open up within us.
And well it is also dialogue
between self and soul, right?
It is so old, it is a Yates.
It is before Yates.
It is you know aspects of yourself
speaking and answering yourself.
It is a great thing to do.
Everyone today just sit
down and have one part
of yourself ask a question and the
other aspect of yourself answer.
It is fascinating to let yourself
ask questions and answer them.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
No it is beautiful and the way
that it operates I think between,
I do not want to say characters.
But between versions of
the self as they appear.
>> Marie Howe: Yes.
>> Adrian Matejka: In Magdalene
is just so gorgeous too.
>> Marie Howe: Versions
of the self, right?
That is what your book
deals with too.
Because there is the poor,
wonderful, vitally alive kid,
you know trying to stay alive.
And then he gets in the suburbs and
he is still trying to stay alive.
I mean that is what is so great is
that you know he gets to the suburbs
and you think phew good at least.
But no. because that too
is going to be replaced
and replaced and it is so American.
You know, like.
But they are on a driveway that is
one day going to be a parking lot,
that is one day going
to be a playground,
that is one day is going be a mall.
I mean there is this wonderful
sense of the constant replacement
that occurs in this country and
how nothing is rooted you know.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah and have to
think that that operates in terms
of identity, like self identity.
>> Marie Howe: Yes.
>> Adrian Matejka:
And gender identity.
How does that work for you,
like that sort of [inaudible].
>> Marie Howe: Well it is the same.
I mean especially now.
I do not mean to keep talking
about myself as a woman.
But I am. So I feel as if.
That is what I mean.
Like I do not mean
to keep narrowing.
I mean to broaden it.
That every male has a feminine,
every woman has a masculine
and this integration.
And of course.
But so the patriarch is
quite different from men.
You know, men are wonderful.
But the patriarchal values, which
have subjugated women and the Earth
and the whole thing
has forced woman,
like people of color you know.
Like to be pushed down in a
way so that the energy actually
in those beautiful
energies is coming forth now
and has been for decades
and decades.
And it is healing.
And so a lot of the, a lot has to be
sort of sung to, to come back alive.
You know women's sexuality
is not at odds
with women's spirituality, right?
Women as a mother is not at odds
with her as a sexual, erotic person.
I mean these things have been split.
So to bring them back.
>> Rob Casper: On that note,
you should get a copy
of both of these books.
They will be signing down stairs.
Magdalene and Map to the Stars.
Thank you to our wonderful poets.
I am so happy they met
each other in front of you.
[Applause].
>> Marie Howe: Thank you, Rob.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.